make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and i
was actually gonna release this video to
coincide with falcon and the winter
soldier episode number one just kind of
taking a shot because i didn't really
know if john walker was going to appear
in that series i'm kind of glad i didn't
not so much because john walker didn't
appear he did uh but because of the fact
that it would have been a massive
spoiler in hindsight so
uh what i want to do is go ahead and
release this now since john walker is
kind of the character a lot of people
are going to be talking about
and so when it comes to him john walker
first appeared in captain america comics
issue number 323 and he was created by
mark gruenwald but something that i want
to talk about here for a second
is the nature of captain america comics
at the time because to understand the
significance of john walker you kind of
have to understand captain america the
idea was that the the last significant
writer captain america had before mark
gruenwald showed up
was roger stern and john byrne and of
course john burn was the artist roger
stern was the writer and while their run
only lasted about nine issues it was a
pretty fun and adventurous run
the issue with this is that captain
america's stories especially following
roger stern's completion when all you
really had was just a series of interim
writers right chris claremont jim
shooter al milgram there wasn't really a
whole lot going on with this character
and for a long long time
captain america was just kind of facing
off against the villains of the week
and the only thing that really kept
captain america comics alive was the
fact that it was captain america right
the name recognition
it was one of those things where stanley
and jack kirby brought him back in
avengers number four with a bit of a
tease in a previous story where it
actually turned out to be a villain by
the name of acrobat or something along
those lines and and the result was that
people wanted to see him come back but
it was difficult to write a story about
captain america
that didn't involve him facing off
against some sort of threat against the
united states right so you had him
facing off against forces during the
cold war you had him facing off against
iran in the 70s it was one of those
those
you know weird and wonky situations and
so when mark greenwald took over the
title
the desire of mark was to basically
create villains or characters that
captain america could fight
that were holy captain america villains
right to basically give him his own
rogues gallery which is something that
he never really had and that's why us
agent john walker proved to be so
popular in his initial outing
because he was kind of the antithesis to
steve rogers now the reality is that
unlike a lot of writers today
back then in the 1970s and 1980s
especially when he got to 86 with
captain america 323
that the the nature of writing comics
was to play the long game and it hadn't
always been that way right you go when
you read stan lee jack kirby it's just
kind of like you know things are
happening right and the way that you see
comics happen now is actually very
reminiscent of stan lee and jack kirby
but because the popularity and i kind of
hate to see you know to keep kind of
harping on this but it really is a true
statement
because of the popularity of chris
claremont and the x-men and the idea
that playing the long game
and building characters up is more of a
soap opera type story focusing on the
character development
and maybe secondary focusing on like the
crazy events going on
that this was kind of adopted almost
universally across marvel comics which
is one of the reasons why marvel
became so astronomically popular in the
late 1970s going throughout the entirety
of the 1980s and especially in the early
to mid 1990s and so the result of this
is that in his original appearance in
captain america 323 we didn't really
know much about john walker he was
somebody just going by the name
of the super patriot and basically
discredited captain america right
arguing that he essentially was the guy
who really understood what america was
supposed to be about now a lot of this
was mark gruenwald kind of taking like
the current state of america at the time
a lot of the issues that america had and
using super patriot to paint this
picture that captain america just
wasn't really doing enough right captain
america was out of touch and that was a
great way to segue into john walker
because for anybody who was sitting down
and reading captain america or getting
into comics at the time
one of the basic questions they had even
if it only came from a place of being
intrigued was how does a man who's been
frozen in ice for
a few decades somehow come back and
remain relevant in the modern era right
he hasn't really
seen society progress but this was also
kind of capitalized on magrunwald by
basically saying that captain america's
ideologies and what he stands for
are basically timeless right they they
stand the test of time no matter what
era society is living in right so kind
of using it to
maintain the nature of what steve rogers
stood for and so the result of this is
that the story is pretty straightforward
right i mean it was literally just a
series of of campaigns to discredit
steve rogers and that's really all you
get from his character right you don't
really get a whole lot doing there
instead what we have from his origin
comes from a couple different places
it comes from follow-up stories that
took place in captain america
specifically in issue 328
as well as the current run of u.s agent
which marvels released
to coincide with the revelation that u.s
agent is in falcon in the winter soldier
right to kind of
build on the popularity of the show and
so focusing on captain america 328 and
329
with a little bit of involvement from
the current us agent story by
christopher priest which isn't really
isn't really completed what we know is
that he is
he's a guy who was born in georgia and
basically idolized his brother who was a
helicopter pilot but the reality is that
his younger brother ended up killing
himself right ended up taking his own
life now that really is more of a way
for christopher priest to tie into the
idea that those individuals who fight in
war
have these lingering mental issues that
that follow them long after those wars
are completed but the reality of this
is that john walker was always inspired
to live up to his brother's memory now
this is a stark contrast to the way
the character was originally depicted in
marvel comics which is to say that much
like the punisher
that john walker idolized captain
america and just kind of an aside here
for those of you guys who don't know
about that
one of the things that was established
during civil war is that frank castle
went to go fight in vietnam because he
wanted to be like captain america right
that he idolized him that he saw captain
america is just kind of like
this this sort of walking talking uh you
know
concept of what great american ideals
stand for right he just
takes it to the most extreme and kills
villains regardless of what they're
doing uh it's one of these these
one of those twisted moments about the
the punisher but the reality is that
john walker grew up idolizing his
brother and as a result of that wanted
to follow in his brother's footsteps and
he wanted to basically be a
quote-unquote
hero and so what ended up happening is
that in the current us agent run
it ties into what we saw in captain
america 328 and 329 where john walker
basically approached somebody who was
called the power broker now the power
broker is a guy
it's really kind of a company called
power broker incorporated
that was run by a couple guys named carl
mollus and curtis jackson and the whole
idea behind this is that if you had the
money
you could go to the power broker and he
would give you powers right he would he
would literally give you superhero
abilities now what john walker got was
effectively enhancements that put him on
par with steve rogers right enhance
strength speed agility different things
like that and there were limitations to
what the power broker could do he
couldn't give you the power to like
alter reality on a universal scale or
something along those lines right there
were basically limits there but what
ended up happening
is john walker intended to go forward
and join what was called the universal
class wrestling federation
instead he was convinced in order to
become a hero and so the the only real
way he knew to do this was to kind of go
forward and then start questioning
captain america's role
and establishing himself as almost a
replacement the way that mark gruenwald
had basically written him the reality is
that with the original introduction of
john walker
well i wouldn't say it was met with
resounding success and people were just
like
man this guy's amazing you know there
certainly was some intrigue a lot
a lot of it because of the fact that we
just didn't know enough about him right
so people were just
curious about the character and they
wanted to see uh how far this would go
and so what you ended up getting was
mark gruenwald following up with captain
america number 332
which introduced this idea that with the
the commission on superhuman activities
which those of you guys who don't know
what that is the commission on
superhuman activities was
was almost kind of a counterpart to
project wide awake where project wide
awake focused on containing and
controlling the mutant threat that
existed out there the commission on
superhero activities had a liaison named
valerie cooper who basically worked
alongside the federal government and the
superhero community to essentially
monitor them right so think of it as
superhuman registration from civil war
before the events of civil war now
something else to understand here is
that there was a bit of legitimate
experimenting going on here by gruenwald
with the question of like could we
potentially replace steve rogers as
captain america and make somebody else
the character right like what if that
is kind of a added benefit of what we're
doing here which is not uncommon you
oftentimes see marvel taking an existing
hero
and replacing them with somebody else to
see how people respond to it a really
good example is when jane foster became
thor
under jason aaron which was probably one
of the best thor runs of all time
i don't care what anybody says and so
what you ended up finding out here in
captain america issued
number 332 going into 333 and 334
was that the red skull had actually been
manipulating the commission on superhero
activities to get steve rogers out
and so what this meant was that with the
red skull becoming successful steve
rogers was replaced by john walker the
problem with this
is that john walker was far more of an
extreme version of captain america than
steve rogers was
going so far as to like intentionally
inflict harm among
other people and so the the result is
that when you ended up having
the actions of john walker being exposed
publicly people realizing that he was
just
far too extreme of a captain america
followed by steve rogers kind of
changing his name to the captain and
then the two of them teaming up
and basically defeating the red skull it
was deemed that john walker was just too
extreme to be captain america and so
really in this kind of ten part epic
between captain america 341
and 351 john walker was ultimately
removed from the role of of captain
america and it was given back to steve
rogers now a lot of this came by way of
letters pages things like
that where fans basically write in and
marvel publishes those and a lot of fans
just
wanted steve rogers to be captain
america right it's just the way of
things
even if it wasn't necessarily the most
popular character marvel had going at
the time
there was a kind of familiarity among
fans who either didn't like change
enjoy the status quo or fans who were
coming into comics for the first time
and
seeing that like steve rogers was
captain america that peter parker was
spider-man right that professor xavier
was a leader of the x-men there was this
kind of expectation
that you know given whatever sources
brought them into comics that they would
see those characters depicted
in comic books and so i wouldn't say
that john walker playing the role of
captain america was a catastrophic
failure but i will say it was one of
these instances when where mark
gruenwald and marvel kind of realized
okay
there really isn't a whole lot of room
here to replace steve rogers
with somebody else in the role of
captain america that would come later
with bucky barnes and sam wilson
now following this something to
understand is that where mark gruenwald
had initially taken over the writing
duties of captain america at that point
in time
uh jim shooter was editor-in-chief of
marvel right and so jim shooter kind of
ran marvel with an iron fist and so the
idea of hey like if you're gonna create
villains that belong to captain america
like they belong to him right and that's
it
you don't ever really change it up tom
defalco was
a lot more lenient with regards to how
he handled uh marvel characters and was
even
really on par with the idea of like
switching things around and the reason
why this mattered
is because really with this initial i
guess ousting of john walker as steve
rogers nobody really knew what to do
with him and so he did appear
about 10 issues later in captain america
354
uh where he kind of popped back up as
u.s agent and he was facing off against
the iron monger but he had a completely
different look than what we were
familiar with instead he had a whole new
costume
his shield had been shifted like the the
colors the design and everything
was just different from the one that we
were used to but following this
appearance he was ultimately rolled over
into avengers west coast now a little
bit of history here the avengers west
coast team was a team that was created
one by marvel
uh as just kind of an ancillary sort of
what if we can expand the avengers
roster but within comics was formed as a
necessity so the way that played out is
when jim shooter was editor-in-chief and
he orchestrated the original secret war
story due to a potential brand deal
between marvel and mattel
you had the main avengers team which was
basically whisked away to battle world
by the beyonder to face off against the
various villains that had been brought
there as well what it essentially meant
is that earth didn't really have a
superhero team in the form of an
avengers team protecting it and so with
the vision being one of the individuals
who was left behind
what he actually ended up realizing is
that there was an enemy approaching
earth called the dire race who were
basically just an offshoot of the
skrulls but if they were to arrive on
earth there'd be nobody there to keep it
safe
and with x factor essentially being part
of the original secret wars along with
some of the more popular x-men being
there
then there wouldn't really be a whole
lot of protection and so he formed an
ancillary avengers team on the west
coast to basically be a backup team in
case
the main avengers team itself was
unavailable now the reality is that
marvel was just kind of experimenting
and just seeing you know what all was
there but the other part of this
is that with the commission on
superhuman activities while the avengers
west coast team was
relatively popular within marvel comics
by the time the commission became a
thing what you ended up having
was then basically stating if the
avengers west coast team is going to
function in the united states then it
has to do so with government oversight
and so the character of john walker as
us agent
was forced onto the avengers west coast
team which led to people like hawkeye
and i believe mockingbird quitting out
of protest but the
the cool thing about this is that where
there was a lot of
you know disdain for the idea of the
federal government involving itself in
the affairs of the avengers west coast
team
ultimately the way that john walker was
written by john byrne was very very
intriguing
right so the way that this was done was
one of these things where it was kind of
him
in some degree making up atonement for
his past actions when he was captain
america but also being somewhat of a
vigilante guy but where
the avengers west coast run was coming
to a rapid end in the sense that like it
would end with issue number 46 so
literally two issues after john walker
was thrown onto the team
by all standards of measurement he
effectively became the backbone of the
avengers west coast team right he was
their own miniature version of captain
america and that's one of the reasons
why a lot of people
see john walker as kind of a poor man's
captain america
because he i wouldn't say he's a cheap
knockoff or maybe he kind of is
but he was kind of the avengers west
coast own little version of steve rogers
and so what ended up happening is that
with avengers west coast coming to an
end john byrne basically departing and
then uh dan
abner and andy landing taking up the
launch of force works you essentially
had iron man creating his quote-unquote
own superhero team
some people call it like an unofficial
version of the avengers some people
don't
but the important thing about force
works is that initially john walker
didn't want to join he didn't want to be
part of the team he really saw it
as as the idea of the avengers west
coast kind of disbanding as sort of a
failing on his own personal part
and so ultimately he was convinced by
scarlet wits to join and that was a way
for marvel to kind of rework his
character yet again
to give him a new costume to give him an
energy shield different things along
those lines and for the most part the
entire run
of force works as he was a part of it
was cool right it was cool to see him
leading this field team
and almost making up for the past
mistakes that he'd engaged in you also
saw some of his former villains and even
teammates coming back you saw him coming
into conflict with the power broker yet
again things along those lines and then
ultimately his involvement with the
commission which has kind of been this
hold over
ever since the old mark greenwald days
was basically cut off in its entirety
when he ended up getting into a conflict
with war machine and hawkeye uh during
force works issue number 12 where the
series was essentially wrapping up i
mean technically it ran for 22 issues
but it might as well have been finished
by issue number 12. i mean the series
was
it wasn't that great by the time it was
done but following that with force works
basically
coming to an end more or less in the mid
1990s the reality of us agent is he just
ended up becoming one of those
characters
who just kind of bounced around because
marvel never really knew what to do with
them they never really knew
exactly what to do with this character
there was a point when he became part of
a group called the jury
right which was basically just kind of
this this vigilante group that was led
by a guy named edward cord uh and he got
into a battle with the thunderbolts the
thunderbolt series was hugely popular it
ran for like 81 issues all the way up to
2003
but you just saw him kind of move around
from place to place and shift from team
to team
i would say some of the most notable
instances of his time
uh during this this period was when he
became part of a group called
stars which was basically organized by
valerie cooper and is called the
superhuman tactical activities response
squad this was basically just a
government sanctioned team that served
the purpose at least non-mutant team
that was x factor at the time but it was
a non-mutant government sanctioned team
that served the purpose of dealing with
various superhuman threats that existed
out there the reality is that it may
there may have been instances when the
group had to face off against
superheroes and that's the reason why
john walker was inducted as part of the
team is that while he was
to a degree a hero he was more of an
anti-hero than anything else and so by
being part of the star's team
sometimes he was a good guy sometimes he
was a bad guy it depended on the
situation that he was in
and that kind of bouncing back and forth
became a mainstay of his character one
of the notable instances of this was
during the events of civil war when he
actually sided in favor of superhuman
registration and ultimately face off
against the forces of captain america
and his secret avengers but again that's
one of the things that was sort of
intriguing about him is that he just
sort of moved and gravitated but i will
say
probably one of the single most
important moments of his character
really came by way of the really the
lead up to the events of secret empire
and the reason why is because during
that point in time during rick remembers
run on captain america
by and large a lot of work had been done
with steve rogers leading up to that
specifically during ed brubaker's run
ed brubaker had brought back bucky
barnes who had been gone from the marvel
landscape for
years and years and years um ed brubaker
had actually changed up a lot of the
history there so
in the older stories by marvel comics
when captain america was fighting
against communists and then there was no
real
continuity there in terms of how he
could be frozen in ice but fight against
communists at the same time that he
shifted that up and say that essentially
any version of captain america and bucky
barnes that you saw
after the end of world war ii were
basically stand-ins there were people
pretending to be captain america because
nobody really knew where steve rogers
was they assumed that he was he was
killed in action and so rick remender
basically came back in towards the end
of his run
and basically had a story called the
nail where steve rogers lost the super
soldier serum it was essentially
taken away from his body and he just
aged up into an old man and so what this
meant was that the stage was effectively
set
for a new captain america bucky barnes
already been captain america at one
point in time
following the death of steve rogers or
the perceived death of steve rogers
after the events of civil war and so you
couldn't really do the same
gag twice and so what rick remember did
is he wrote all new all different
captain america where sam wilson became
the new the new captain america
character now the reality of this
is that sam wilson the way he was
written at the time was largely
overwhelmed by his role of of being the
captain
america s character because the reality
was steve rogers was really supposed to
be or really the captain america
character was supposed to be beholden to
a series of ideologies without any
particular bias towards any particular
thing right so long as those ideologies
uh
embody what is in effect truth justice
in the american way
then captain america was always in the
good the way this played out though was
you actually had a story that took place
in captain america sam wilson issue
number 12
where you in effect had uh sam wilson
facing off against what were called the
americops now the americops were a group
created by a guy named paul keane
that was originally designed to be a
kind of uh
accompaniment to existing police
officers to face off against you know
whatever threats may overwhelm cops
the truth about it is that the americops
just ended up profiling and
cracking down hard on poor minorities in
america and so sam wilson who was being
written as
a captain america that was more in line
with
what were in effect ideologies that were
focused on more progressive ideals and
standing up for minorities
ended up coming into conflict with the
americops and the way this was was sort
of orchestrated the way this was
depicted to john walker was by a
combination of paul keane
and tom harold who was a texas senator
in manhattan and they essentially
painted this picture
that uh that sam wilson was not fit for
the shield that sam wilson while he was
largely rejected by the american people
by virtue of his actions facing off
against the cops was being depicted as a
guy who was quote unquote
anti-american right he was attacking the
police now u.s agent
immediately saw right through this right
the way that he was written was what he
immediately saw right through this and
he called the bluff and said no like i'm
not doing that i'm not
going out there to confront sam wilson
and taking the shield away from him
because he's standing up for people who
are being abused by what is in effect a
corrupt police force
and so this led to steve rogers showing
up and then basically asking us
agent to go and get the shield from sam
wilson because he's obviously not
qualified to be captain america now the
big question that a lot of people had at
this point in time was
why would that play out right why would
we have this version of captain america
this version of steve rogers doing that
now the reality is
nick spencer was the one who was writing
captain america at this point in time
with regards to sam wilson facing off
against the the americans and so on and
while there was a
was a very a very big rift among captain
america fans as to whether or not nick
spencer's run was good
i thought it was fantastic it's probably
the single greatest captain america run
that anybody's ever written but this
basically
revealed the idea that during the events
of avengers standoff that the red skull
had managed to get his hands on a cosmic
cube that it kind of reformed itself
into a young girl
and then he used that power to rewrite
all of steve rogers history and
effectively established that steve
rogers has always been a hydra agent
and so with that being the case steve
rogers going in here and then
orchestrating a conflict between us
agent and sam wilson and then having us
agent try to take the the shield from
sam wilson was designed to basically be
a distraction which would essentially
allow him and the rest of hydra to
conquer washington dc through a series
of
really subterfuge missions and tricking
the government and even the superhero
community itself and then ultimately
conquering the united states which is
exactly what captain america did during
the events of secret empire
he basically conquered america and is
probably one of the best stories ever
but more recently with us agent you've
basically seen marvel
relaunching him and going through and
essentially giving us like a
kind of a rework of his origin story i
will say it's written by christopher
priest it's pretty good but the problem
christopher priest has is he writes
out of time so like he'll give you
what's going on right now then he'll
jump forward five months then he'll jump
back a year and a half then he'll jump
forward by like three weeks
then he'll go back like like 15 years
ago it's it's really really confusing
and it can really really throw you off
it certainly reads better in trade
i will say but at the moment you know
that's kind of the nature of us agent
right john walker was in effect a guy
who was brought in to be a replacement
captain america he proved to be too
extreme
he was involved in the the west coast
avengers team as basically a field head
uh leading the team itself ultimately
became part of iron man's own little
avengers
force works teams and then just kind of
bounced around marvel comics ever since
with nobody really having any idea what
to do with them so uh with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign